what's something uncommon that you find
attractive about
men foreign
[Laughter]
that's what i notice right away forearms
and posture
posture really yeah because i can tell
if you're in the military or not and
that's like the one that freaks me out a
little bit
because i'm like military guys baggage
yeah
i don't know
he was in the military he was yeah
oh i was engaged fun fact you were
engaged yeah
what what life have you lived oh crazy
one
wait so you're engaged to this guy
and like what happened what what
happened well i said no
okay i guess he went to my dad to ask
for my hand in marriage and my dad's so
nice and he was like i'm sure she'll
make the right decision
what was wrong with him
um
mentally unstable
oh okay
yeah
but
and he didn't pay for anything so
and he kind of moved himself in
oh so it was like a it was like a son
husband
yeah
yeah
yeah
so my last my last boyfriend moved in
with my family
yeah honestly
but you guys weren't dating yet right
you're like just so
oh that was i forgot that happened too
no it was like
when we first met he stayed at my
family's house for like a week yeah but
then he actually moved in when we were
dating after like a month
because he was getting an apartment and
they needed to put him on the lease so
he could get an id yeah yeah but that
was yeah
sorry i'm messing with body lights
honestly though like
if my
parents were cool not that they're not
cool but my mom has like mental health
problems or whatever i would so do that
because then you can see how they act
around family and stuff
yeah it's kind of a big deal if you come
from a family of like 100
or giants
oh by the way guys today is torsh's
birthday so put happy birthday to her in
the chat
oh
everyone or your mom happy birthday
so one thing that i think is attractive
about guys that's uncommon is vocal
tonality that's not uncommon
is it
i just never hear girls talk about it
but a guy with a nice deep voice i'm
like
oh yeah that's how i became attracted
attracted to my ex my more recent one i
guess if you want to say recent
really yeah
voice hell yeah he had a ted talk so hot
yeah it's a huge thing maybe that's why
girls tend to go for men
you know out of their race because they
have deeper voices like baritone
i don't know
i feel the same way about a woman with a
nice deep voice am i weird
yeah a little bit it's typically higher
pitched that men prefer they like the
vocal cry actually do you know that
no what's that
vocal cry um yeah
okay hold on
okay i'm gonna beat
kourtney kardashian
and she's just like i
just
want to spend time with my kids
i
don't
those go over my boundaries
do you hear it i don't know
no i don't i don't know what you're
doing
like is it like the vocal fry
yeah
yeah maybe i heard it maybe i heard
maybe that's why i like pearl so much
damn
did he just say you have a dude voice
yeah damn
it's okay i have a low voice
who cares [ __ ] them
i think it's annoying do you remember
that show i don't own a tv so i'm gonna
need a lot of help when describing it
but it's the show where they're all in
different apartments and they're texting
it's kind of like the bachelor but on
your phone
anyway so you fall in love that way and
then you meet each other
and
i forget what it's called if anybody
knows it's going to bother me because i
don't know if pearl knows what i'm
talking about but there was this couple
that was a meme and the girl
had this vocal cry baby voice and she
would switch into the baby voice very
often and that's the reason that he was
attracted to her and i was like that's
so annoying like when i want something
and i'm a baby you know
yeah that's odd can you please
no
he and it was
it was a topic for a while
that guys are attracted to that
i was like no [ __ ] i thought i was being
annoying
damn
that's another thing
what do you first yeah most about a guy
other than height
um
smile maybe
like eyes
spies
smile with their eyes
yeah or just like their energy to be
honest but like
[Laughter]
oh yeah i forget that it's true though
it's like the way a guy carries himself
like women can pick up on a lot more
than men can pick up on and it's posture
that's why i said it i think posture
and the way that a guy moves
kind of together because when somebody's
awkward their posture is usually like
mine right now where it's kind of like
like hiding yourself
and then you have a guy that just
doesn't give a [ __ ] wow my shoulders are
so turned in but they're just like
walking around like
straight and i don't know
i don't know
and then yeah and then it kind of goes
to their confidence too like how they
hold carry themselves
that's why
that stuff isn't really taught though
like i have very awkward body language
me too it's very like i kind of humorous
um
yeah i kind of wish it was like taught
like it would have been something that'd
been good to learn
i don't think you're that awkward to be
honest with you i actually think you're
more extroverted
oh i am
but it's like um
just like where do you put your hands
type [ __ ]
it's like okay when i take a picture i
like don't know what to do with my body
i'm like no one does
no
always create your hair um if you're
gonna take a picture with a girl most
girls will do the hip thing what i do is
i do it in the back though and then
you're kind of like forced into like a
comfortable more comfortable position
or i just avoid photos and hopefully
it's
uh
facing you so you can see
[Music]
but i don't think you're awkward at all
i think you just think you're awkward
i
think i still think of awkward
nobody that's actually awkward as hell
would go to like the pua thing like that
takes balls
just saying oh i'm ballsy but like
awkward people could still be ballsy
i'm just bold so you're saying that you
have awkward mannerisms without the
anxiety
yeah that's crazy to me yeah like
yeah like like
i don't care like i'm awkward and i just
don't care but you can't
if you watch my videos that's why people
think of buddies because i'm kind of
awkward
yeah
yeah that's what that's what that's like
that entertainment value true
yeah just awkward i never really noticed
it yeah and i just don't
or maybe like
like i don't know i don't think
like i think you're more anxious than
awkward to be honest but maybe it's just
because you're really hot
like respectfully i just don't like when
people
turn from what they're doing to look
it's always okay it just it's even
though i know that people will just look
and like look back i just don't like it
i don't know why
it's like i should be flattered
but it's been like that since i was like
13 so it's kind of like
gross
and to be honest with you
oh my gosh you think anyone's gonna call
in
we'll see you you had you had him so
quick on your show